the radio show we're outside the studio
with Danny Maness of no bull scripted
consulting how's it going guys we had a
wonderful interview and we have some
additional questions one of which is of
the clients that you've worked with how
many of them have gone on to have an
actual movie made from the scripts that
you've consulted well none um none of
them made I've only been doing it for
about 18 months of nilval scripts been
running for about 18 months and
obviously it takes years to get a movie
made
I've had one script sale which is
variants in development now I've had
quite a few contest winners the winner
of the creative screenwriting Expo TV
contest was a client I've had a Disney
fellowship winner I've had a couple of
people land managers or in the process
of landing managers but it's a process
if you're going to a script with Sultan
because you think you're going to sell
that script it's not really the reason
to use a consultant you know we're there
to help get your script better to help
improve your writing ability tell you
where you're going wrong and hopefully
make that script a good writing sample
for you to either get a manager maybe
even an option but the chances of any
movie gating getting made is is really
really low so getting your first script
made is like lightning in a bottle
you know it's 99.99% of first script
don't ever get produced so you have to
look at submitting your script to a
consultant and getting feedback as a
learning process as something that's
going to help you in your next script
and and improve your tone so that you
can land a manager or win a contest get
meetings get read those should be your
goals when you're first starting out
then once you know a little bit more and
you've had a couple scripts under your
belt then start you know
really pushing on how to sell your sugar
to get it made so you know we're still
working I wish only my clients could get
their scripts made and bought and
produced I wish my own scripts would get
made and bought and produced you know
but um it's you know it's a fight and so
if you go into anything whether it's a
pitch maestro consultancy with with the
thought of I'm gonna get a three-picture
deal you're gonna be sorely sorely
disappointed but if you go in with you
know I want to become a better writer I
want to learn I want to improve my
project and my abilities that that is
what a consultant will do for you should
do for you being in LA you know
everybody has a title of some sort you
know a multi - it probably usually
filmmaker director you know screenwriter
whatever and there's a lot of people
here that they say that there are these
things and then they waste a lot of time
and they don't really put effort toward
it
what do screenwriters do to kind of
waste time and make believe that they're
working but they're actually not being
effective in their day what what are
some of the things and what are some of
the things that they should actually be
doing to make them effective I am a
horrible procrastinator I waste time
like nobody's business
and I'm really good at it so but yeah
that is one of the pitfalls is there's
so much busy work that you can find
yourself busy with in the day that you
don't actually get your writing done and
so you know like me you know I write
articles every week for a couple
different websites publications whatever
so if I sit down you know it's a lot
easier for me to finish an article and
you know write a 1,500 word 2,000 word
article than it is for me to sit down
and write 10 pages of the project that I
should be writing so I get that and I
think everybody goes everybody goes
through that so I mean everyone has
their own formats you can even do the
egg timer thing if it works for you for
me it doesn't because I live alone
I work you know alone and so nobody
knows if that egg timer goes off you
know
me so it doesn't work for me I think it
is good to set a time limit for yourself
I've made to-do lists every day since I
was 10
seriously and so I feel bad if I don't
get a lot of stuff on that to-do list
done so make your to-do list and and
just fine time corner off that bit of
time in your day to try and get that
writing done but there is a lot of other
stuff that goes on in you know that goes
into this business and screenwriting so
if you are doing your research if you
are reading the trades if you are
reading blogs and learning if you are
reading articles you know that's part of
it that's part of the setup to getting
ready to write and so don't feel bad
about it
don't don't beat yourself up for it does
that we'll just cause even more mental
anguish and then you won't want to write
it and then you'll just give up and
stuff like that so I mean do what you do
all that busy stuff get it out of the
way and so you have no excuse not to
write and then sit down for 20 minutes
30 minutes and and try to write
something but you know research is
important and so don't don't discount
that